こんにちは はじめしゃちょーです
というわけで
これやばいんだ多分、うまい棒90万円分くらいあんのかな
結構食ったんすけど全然減らなかったんで
あの本当に物凄い数のうまい棒に
なってしまいました
ていうわけで今日はこのうまい棒を皆さんに無料で配ろうと思います
これ全部ですからね
やべー
これｗｗｗこれぇ
何するかっつうと言うとうまい棒配るんですよ
やばいよー
ほんとに…
あのー100万円企画でまぁ軽い気持ちっていうわけじゃなかったんですけど
まぁそれなりの数を覚悟してうまい棒を買ったんですけど多すぎて
実は会場借りたり色々してると
ものすごいお金がかかってしまってて参ったって感じです
まぁでもそれで
俺以外のみんなが笑顔になってくれるんだったら
会場費、運営費なんて
というわけで今日はみなさんにうまい棒を
これ全部配っていこうと思います
バイバイ
今日ハタチの誕生日のお方がいらっしゃいます
おめでとうございます
みなさま〜今日なんと！
なんとですね
お姉ちゃんの誕生日でございます
おめでとうとうございます
6月に彼氏できた？おめでとうございます
女の子：ありがとうございます
はい、お気をつけて　ありがとうございました
本当にありがとうございました
というわけで、うまい棒配り終わりました　ありがとうございました
はい、というわけで
うまい棒90万円分ぐらいかな配り終わりました
来てくださった皆様本当にありがとうございまし…たっ
キッツー
はい、というわけでうまい棒配布会
来てくださった皆様
無事皆様のおかげで全部のうまい棒なくなりました
ふーーーーー
いやぁ難かしかったっすねー
なんかうまい棒も何本残ってるかわかんないし
イベントに来る人が全員100％来るわけもないから
何人に何本あげればちゃんとなくなるかってのがわかんなかったんで
もう配る数が本当に難しかったです
せっかく来たのにもらえないっていうのも嫌だし
余りすぎると本来の目的を見失うことになってしまうし
一応ですねあの来てくれた方全員に
数は結構差があるとは思うんですけど
うまい棒は全部配ることができました
結構皆さん喜んでくれて何よりでございます
き つ かっ たぁ
マジでキツかったぁよぉ
1700人に休憩無しでもうずっと配り続けてて　中腰で
腰を痛めてしまいました　ありがとうございました
それでももう元をたどれば100万円分うまい棒を買ってしまった僕のせいなので
まぁそのおかげでなんか皆さんとお話できたり会えたりできたんで
あの…まぁ…
結果オーライってとこかな
お暑い中来てくださった皆様　ありがとうございました
ちょっとあの、一言言いたいことがあるんですけども
なんかコメントとかリプとかで
なんかうまい棒それ全部被災地に送ってくださいとか
なんか今洪水とかで大変な地域とかになんかうまい棒全部送れよとか
結構言われたりするんですけども
僕それは断じて違うかなと思っております
本当に今
その地域にうまい棒が必要なのかと言われると
僕はちょっとわかんないです正直
なんかむしろ必要ないものを
必要ないものを必要ない時に送られる方が
すごいあの現地からすると迷惑な行為なのかなと
僕は思いました
もちろん必要とあれば僕は送りたいと思っております
ただその必要か必要じゃないかと判断がつかないうちに
もう勢いでそのうまい棒全部被災地に送ったりするのは
うーん　ちょっと俺は違うかなと思いました
僕は何かあった時になんでもかんでも送っていいとは思っておりません
なんかそういうイベントするんだったら被災地に送れっていうコメントをたくさんみて
う〜ん俺ちょっと
それ今は、今はね
今は違うんじゃないかなって素直に思いました
なので僕は送りません　今は
必要か必要じゃないかちゃんと見極めて
必要な時にちゃんと僕のできることを
ちゃんとやっていきたいと思います
というわけで無事家にたっくさんあったうまい棒がなくなりましたが
うまい棒配るイベント
結構色々お金かかったんすよ
うまい棒を配るためにかかった金額全部合計してみると大体…
てへ
字幕作成者もイベント参加してきて
会場にはたくさんのうまい棒と
笑顔が溢れていました
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】
(長時間本当にお疲れ様でした)
あ　り　が　と